أجعل من السهل على النيجيريين
إعادة تدوير اسمي Willie keys Arabia
viola وأنا صانع تغيير
[موسيقى].
كيف تصنع نموذجًا قابلاً للتطبيق
لجمع البلاستيك على نطاق واسع ،
صدقني ، إنه سؤال صعب للغاية
خاصةً عندما تضع في اعتبارك
مدينة التحدي مثل Legos
التي تواجه هذا التحدي هو سبب
تكريم بيليكيس وشقيقها من
قبل ملك وملكة بلجيكا في هذا
الحدث الفخم في القصر الملكي
للنبوة ولكن من أجل الحصول
على فرصة للحب بين أفراد العائلة المالكة
وكبار الشخصيات
بيليكيس قضوا فترة  الكثير من الوقت بين
القمامة في نيجيريا ، فأنت تعلم أن هذا النوع من
القمامة لم يتم جمعه ، ينتهي به الأمر كما
تعلم إلى الذهاب إلى الصرف الصحي ونحن في
الواقع ندخل وننظف كل هذا ، فأنت
تعرف هذه الأنواع من الأشياء ونظهر
للناس أن مجتمعاتهم يمكن
أن تكون نظيفة بالفعل  ولكن لمجرد التحلي
بالشفافية ، قمنا بتنظيف هذا الأمر
منذ حوالي شهرين ، وهذا ما نعود إليه
الآن وما نحاول القيام به
كإعادة التدوير كطلاب جامعيين شرقيين حتى لا
يتخلصوا من  سلة المهملات لأن القمامة
ذات قيمة في الواقع ، ستعمل على تمكينهم من
تمكين الناس من القمامة الخاصة بهم ،
وهذا هو الأساس وراء جمال الأعمال الذي
بدأ في عام 2012 ، حيث قاموا بإحضار
بعض نفايات البلاستيك وهم يجلبون
هذا كل يوم عندما تجلب هؤلاء النساء
الكلاسيكيات التي استخدمناها  جمعت النقاط المعينة
بناءً على الأوزان التي
تضيفها النقاط وبعد فترة زمنية معينة يمكنهم
استبدال النقاط إما بهدية
لإعادة التدوير النقدي يكسبون المال عن طريق تجميع
المواد القابلة لإعادة التدوير وبيعها
لمشترين بلاستيك دوليين ، يمكنه بسهولة
إنشاء مصنع لإعادة التدوير ولكن  إذا
لم يكن لديك شبكة تجميع حيث
يمكنك فعلاً جمع القمامة
بطريقة موثوقة ، فهذا يعني أنها ميتة من
خلال تحفيز الناس على جمع
وإعادة تدوير المواد القابلة لإعادة التدوير الخاصة بهم ، فقد قامت
الشركة بتحويل شعب نيجيريا
إلى شبكة مجموعتهم مع كل
خطأ صغير لذلك هي  جلب
القمامة لدينا ونحن نحصل على أساس يومي
يشعرون وكأنهم يمتلكون الأعمال التجارية وهو أمر
جيد وكذلك بالنسبة لك  أنت تفكر في أننا نجرب
الفصل ، إنه عمل مجتمعي ، لذا
نريد التأكد من أننا قريبون جدًا من
المجتمع